should a guy pay on the first date
because pearl and i had this
debate today earlier in the phone the
girl should offer to pay and i don't
think the man should be responsible
to pay i can afford to pay for my own
stuff like pearl and i even talked about
like chivalry and how
men should open the door because you
know that is a sign that someone is
serious
but i don't need a dude to do that i'm a
perfectly capable woman
who can like flip the bill
the date that i just went on i like what
i did is i paid for dinner and then she
paid for her dessert like i think that's
fair and we did that for the rest of the
time went on dates like if we went to an
event
i'd pay for the event or vice versa and
then she'd pay for whatever we do next
so we would just go back and forth and i
think that's a good balance to have yeah
i don't agree
um sorry i'm all about women's
empowerment but i think i'm empowered to
have a standard that the guy on the
first date can pay for dinner
um like my standard for going on a date
with someone is that he can afford
dinner
that's that's for me though i don't care
if ari does that like i just prefer it
the other way